on est en train de récolter la carotte
nouvelle on voit là une partie de
l'équipe on est neuf en ce moment sur la
terre voici une ferme maraîchère créer
un proximité d'orléans 2014 par un
ingénieur de formation sur une surface
de 3 hectares le site a récemment pris
de l'ampleur puisque un associé est
arrivé l'exploitation est passé à 12
hectares et la production de légumes
sera bientôt multiplier par deux le taux
quasiment sans être de la politique
agricole commune
pour nous c'est ça représente très peu
ses étés je disais 700 euros d aides pac
donc c'est pas du tout lié à la valeur
enfin à tous qu'on va apporter sur le
territoire là nous on va maintenant avec
l'agrandissement de la ferme on va
arriver à plus de 10 personnes
embauchées sur la ferme dont la plupart
en cdi et on sait pas du tout valorisé
par des aides pac
la confédération paysanne considère cet
exemple comme une forme d'injustice et
souhaite un nouveau modèle de politique
agricole commune un système privilégiant
des exploitations de taille modeste
moyenne employant de la main d'oeuvre
grâce à des soutiens financiers et
utilisant tous les circuits courts de
commercialisation pour rétribuer d'abord
les agriculteurs l'état des discussions
sur la future pac ne rassure pas la
confédération paysanne sa volonté de
soutien spécifique aux petites
exploitations et de primes favorisant
plutôt l'emploi que la surface cultivée
n'apparaît pas dans la nouvelle réforme
on va rester sur un statu quo on va
mettre des nouveaux noms derrière et
puis
on va pas bouger trop trop grand chose
et puis on a un défi quand même c'est la
souveraineté alimentaire où on est
importateur de protéines on est
importateur à 50 % de fruits et légumes
et jusque là aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'
aide sur le production de protéines
n'est pas dead pour la production de
fruits et légumes
la confédération paysanne ne croient pas
un réquilibrage assurée par la future
pac
elle espère en revanche une correction
des disparités grâce aux arbitrages
effectués par l'état français
c'est tout l'objet des discussions du
psn le programme stratégique national
chargé de redistribuer chaque année les
9 milliards dette de la politique
agricole commune dévolu aux agriculteurs
français